ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show back in studio
how exciting just got back from
australia the tour is over very excited
to put out
a special in early june and you know
what's fun about the special is it has a
ton of material about covid and the
riots so it's going to be really
relevant like that's what's good about
it
it's june so you could uh hear about
covid and nurses and riots and that's
what's the best thing about the special
is it's
perfect pitch perfect in terms of
relevance
and uh it'll it'll it'll take you back
so if you want to go back in time to one
of the worst times that you were ever in
you can go back in time with my
completely
irrelevant special
that will come out in early june
that no one will care about and i don't
even care about but what's good about it
is that i wanted to do the show live as
much as i could so we didn't put it out
earlier so now we've waited till june so
it'll have maximum effect
it's just like it's 2020 all over again
in my comedy special except there's more
to it than that there's other stuff i i
talk about uh pizza hut it's not only uh
covet
there's other stuff uh just got back
from australia the land down under very
exciting um hospitable people lovely
people recapped it on the patreon
um
myself ben sam talent we're still
feeling the jet lag how are you
doing not great how are you
i'm not fair
you know i'm i'm learning to live with
it
uh
and while we were over there in uh
australia
keeping uh tabs on all the podcasts beef
we um
were reading
stories and the news and
one of the stories i read was about this
band d antwoord is that how you
pronounce it that's right i believe it
is now de antwoord is a uh south african
hip-hop duo
and they do the zeph style of stuff
which i believe is a lot of gold and
it's very they're very brash
and they live in south africa and they
adopt like all these deformed people
and they run around the woods with
machetes and they take bath salts it's
it's something different you know
something it's it's nice it's different
and it's made up of yolandi visser and
uh uh ninja and ninja and uh lovely
people from i'm sure from all accounts
now uh and they are
google what the zeff style is because
they have this unique their videos got
crazy views because they were very
unique
i find you freaky and i like you a lot
you know rich [ __ ] that was a good song
rich [ __ ]
nutella amazoni nutella on the sami
because in south africa if you have
nutella on a sandwich it means you're
rich
nutella omasami
so zev is the south african counter
culture movement uh kyle hans brockman
has compared zev counterculture to
a lot of subcultures in the northern
hemisphere i don't know what that means
i want to know what it is but
from what i think it is it is very like
um
zeff music and culture the music group
the ant word self identifies as zeph in
a 2010 interview ninja of the edward
responded to the controversy arising
from his claim that zeph represented
south africa
critics suggested it might rather just
represent afrikaans while south africa
he commented that racism is somewhat
obsolete and a thing of the past for
south africa what is
so i think this is his yeah zeph is
you're poor but you're fantastic you're
poor but you're fancy you're you're
ghetto fabulous
right
okay that's what it is zeph style and
it's fun and enjoyable
and so
these people dee antwoord
uh
adopted uh kind of this disfigured
child yes and
named
taki yeah that's what he looks like
there now
taki is now accusing them of being
abusive he is uh
saying that
he was he's accusing them of physical uh
sexual abuse and slavery
and
um
he said uh
he has a rare disease
and he said quote they made me believe i
was the devil buddy that's all parents
they made me believe i was the devil
they made me swear more and made me
believe that i could burn people in hell
and then i'm the king of hell it sounds
a little nice
they told me that i could bring i wish
my parents told me i was the king of
anything taki
they told me that i could bring darkness
upon the world
so he said and i read another thing i
think it was in the guardian he said um
the worst part was seeing my supposed to
be mother or adopted mother being naked
in a room drunk experiencing my mother
being drunk naked and wanting me to
spend
time with her in the room uh while she
was naked i find that very disturbing
last december ninja and then apparently
took my sister into a sauna and everyone
was naked in the sun and wanted my
sister to get naked too
it's pretty weird this is tacky
uh it felt like a pervy vibe to me every
time when he phones the family they ask
if my sister is pregnant yet and that's
not going to happen not on my watch
this is their adopted son taki
uh
in the video interview uh he said he had
stabbed his older brother three times
leaving him needing hospital treatment
and that uh
ninja and yolandi's response was to
congratulate him they were like quote
hey good job man i didn't actually know
you were going to be a man i didn't
expect you to stab your brother that's
amazing
um
he also accused them of some other
things like they like uh
i think it might have been in a guardian
article i read or something where he was
basically saying like they made him
participate in blood rituals and they
were taking them to a blood bank oh yeah
i read that too yeah something about
that
let's see here um
it's hard to know
because they adopt this kid
who is a
has problems
and
yeah here we go this wasn't the guardian
what was this this is uh the south
african.com south african yeah blood
rituals porn and violence the ant words
child slave tells all
here's the thing about uh sotaki
they picked him up in his community of
faith
at the time and man but you want to talk
about accents that are horrible
i mean the south african accent is the
worst accent it sounds like an
australian like uh
it just has like uh uh uh uh it has down
syndrome it's like wrong
it's horrible
so it's fantastic
uh he said in an interview my mother
said it was gonna be a good experience
so i went
imagine d'antwer shows up and the
mother's like yeah it's gonna be great
get in the car
um
[Music]
the controversial
group whose music includes the lyrics
and imagery based on satanism
gangsterism incest and other social ills
use the children as actors and props in
their music videos and album covers
uh
he said that they split their time
between cape town and johannesburg and
also in los angeles well of course
um
he has a rare skin disease and they took
him in
and uh some of the allegations include
that he was exposed to pornography and
sex toys
uh
the sauna stuff the naked stuff
taking the children to a private clinic
to allegedly have their blood withdrawn
for a blood ritual
congratulating him after he stabbed his
brother
making taki and his friends reenact the
violent stabbing scenes in their music
videos taki discovering black magic in a
box in their family home and partaking
in rituals exposing the children to
dangerous gangsters
uh here's the thing and taki
i my heart goes out to you here but you
have to be a little realistic
there's there wasn't a line of people
at
going to adopt you you know
like there wasn't
they weren't breaking down the doors
to to get in there
and
put the presents under the christmas
tree
sometimes in life when people show you
kindness
it does come with some unwanted
aspects
uh such as the blood rituals
now
i don't know that uh de-antwerp people
and
i i i they're entertaining
um
but
you know this whole thing really comes
down to three words
and they're the same three words that
you use in any sales
uh arrangement when somebody goes it's
too expensive and you have to use these
three words that kind of uh is what i
would say to kind of talky and those
three words are compared to what
yes it's expensive compared to what the
blood rituals are bad compared to what
what was kind of the other option right
i mean unfortunately
there wasn't a ton
happening
i mean outside of him kind of being in a
rob zombie film it wasn't gonna really
uh pop off here
and it
i think his
sting comes off a little ungrateful
because they
you know they hang out in johannesburg
and it's it's incredibly violent they're
in his gangsters and they do crazy drugs
and they run through the jungle
and they participate in in in rituals
and stuff
you know
you know again
it's not a perfect childhood by any
stretch right
it's not ice skating it's not like
a great like oh easter egg hunt and you
know oh we summer in maine sure you're
not in a main sailing camp taki
but turkey i don't think that
childhood's without its charms
and i don't think that it's right to
come out and completely
throw your parents under the bus just
because they made you uh participate in
uh blood rituals in the jungle
it's kind of the price of fame i live in
los angeles do you know how many well
not really i split my time
but when i'm here i mean do you know how
many people in this town
are partaking in blood rituals just to
get ahead
and can barely even do it
and you know he had a seat at the table
here with deanna and they were they were
big they're it's not they're not huge
now
uh this has kind of hurt them i think do
they have a statement that has yolandi
or ninja do they have a statement do
they want to come on the program and
address this so uh if you google them
getting cancelled they actually got
cancelled for a totally other thing they
smacked a gay rapper that they were in
some feud with right that was it some
musician they weren't interfered with
because they're homophobic according to
this well yeah but i don't know they
were in some feud some guy named andy
butler and
i really
i have no idea what goes on in the zeff
community of south africa and i'm not
going to learn
but yeah i just
so they got canceled over that
and and now the the blood rituals i mean
they just can't catch or break these
people yeah it's a real string of
scandals it's a string of scandals and
it's unfortunate
but taki i guess had enough he said this
isn't the way to live
play a little of him so here's uh i
think this right about here is him
talking about uh
him stabbing his brother
right here right okay here we go
imagine if you had to hear this
in your home
i mean
imagine if you had to hear this this
accent
from hell i mean
ar when he's saying they said i'm the
demon is he sure they're wrong
this accent is preposterous
keep going with this god
then today i was actually sitting and
then like
hold on i think i'm playing it on uh i'm
playing at double speed oh let's see if
it's better single speed okay leave that
in though that was i watched things on
double speed sometimes here so let's go
back and let's see here yeah let's see
if it's now cute
adam you know
you know crosstalk it's even worse
they adopted him and he's complaining
he's complaining
you're complaining
i mean
you should say thank you
so now what's his what's what's he up to
here there were stupid things we also
fought that night when i stabbed him
so like yeah so yeah
i was sleeping in that house in park
first
so then i my brother woke up he went to
the speaker that i took
like in the
earlier day during the day
and then
like
he was looking for the speaker so he
came to me he woke me up
he said like yeah he woke me up and then
i got up and then we started fighting
over a speaker and my phone
and then like when he punched me i took
out the knife from my pocket and then i
stabbed him like three times one in the
neck in the arm i think in the
ribs or something i'm not sure exactly
where
but yeah um and my sister was also there
she saw everything that happened like
she was there
when i looked to the door to go out i
saw my sister and a friend that actually
stays across the road from out
so yeah that kind of missed my whole
mind nothing
did your brother go to hospital
yes he actually like
after i stabbed him i actually pressed
the the alarm the security alarm
like to compare to let a parent meditate
on the security and police everything
responds at once
so i respond i pressed the response
button then i couldn't open the gate
because as soon as the response button
goes off
and i open the gate my brother was going
to be able to be able to run faster out
with me so i close the door behind me
after pressing the alarm then i jumped
over the gate with electrical wire i
shot a few times
fell outside i got up
i got up i ran like a block away i hit
in the bushes
i look i watched the whole thing like
the whole thing how the cops came how
the securities came how the ambulance
came i saw everything like i was just up
the road in the bushes hiding checking
everything you know
and then like feel like it was like two
hours after that i went home
i went to go take a shower one of my
homeboys was actually there in a house
you can also tell you the same story
like our introducing like
in the future whatever like then you can
also tell the same story like his way of
how he saw it but anyway
um that's how it happened like
and like for me it's like i almost
killed my own brother but i also saved
this life but
yeah but it could have been dead
i mean is he is this is he a prize
is this a prize i think he wants to be
an actor no my question is is this a
prize if you adopt this
this is my question and i'm being i'm
being completely honest and serious here
if you adopt this
and this starts stabbing people in the
home
is this a prize
is this a prize could i defend hockey
here
yeah sure all right so big encouragement
everyone will i'm always the monster
i'm always the monster
everyone will defend the guy who just
said he stabbed his brother in the neck
it's my fault it's uh dee antwood's
fault
it's everyone's fault because he's
supposedly traumatized by a couple of
blood rituals a little black magic in
the bush
little black magic in the bush uh is not
a reason to uh attack your brother with
a knife sir
who hasn't done a blood ritual with
their parents in a bush
defend taki
ninja
and uh what's her name yolandi ninja and
yolanda
they knew he fought with his brother a
lot and they encouraged him to be a man
and to to kill his brother and so when
he stabbed him a bunch they said they
shook ninja shook
taki's hand and said congratulations
you've you're you've you're finally a
man you've stuck up for yourself he was
like 12 at the time
well how is it a defense of talking
that's an indictment of the other two
that's not a defense of him
yeah that's fair actually
i mean
i'm told to do a lot of things i don't
do them it's true
he was an impressionable child and maybe
they gave him some false confidence
i'm just listen it from what i surmise
it wasn't a great family unit for anyone
involved
i i don't think it was a a good thing
and i wish everyone the best here i just
you know
yes it's you know but you know the deal
uh when you move in with dee antwoord
right you're not i mean he was too young
to know the deal but his mother should
have known the deal
when she set her child to live with the
ant word
in the middle of some south african
nightmare
i mean the music's fine too but after a
while you're like okay enough already
but to fully enjoy it i think you got to
be on bath salts running around the bush
with a machete
anyway
moving on wish wish them well it's hey
it ain't a hallmark christmas card
that's all
that's all
it's not a hallmark christmas card i
love watches everyone loves watches but
you want to get a good watch for a good
price go to
vincerocollective.com
vincerocollective.com
tim dillon that's pronounced vincero
collective.com tim dillon
i love these watches we're excited to
welcome back some old friends of ours
vincero collective it's a premium
lifestyle brand in san diego carrying
incredible eyewear watches and much more
if you don't know them yet there's no
better time to check them out they just
released the argo automatic a collector
quality dive watch you need to check out
they create exceptionally crafted
ethically made products for today's most
ambitious people modem pieces that
elevate your look and stand the test of
time they're adamant about the process
they design everything in house source
all of their own materials they produce
in small batches and ship right to you
so if you're looking to step your style
up check out finchero's argo and the
rest of their premium collection at our
link
venturacollective.com tim dillon it's a
great way to get a great affordable
watch and support our show i have one
ben has one we love them
uh and here's a return policy we get
that online shopping can be frustrating
will this fit will it really look like
this will it be broken in a week
ventura's five year guarantee and 365
day free return policy has you covered
but you don't need to take my word for
it with over thirty thousand five star
reviews features in forbes business
insider and newsweek just to name a few
ventura offers you a shopping experience
you can trust i love argo and i love uh
all of the promotions because you're
getting 20 off and free shipping that's
[ __ ] insane go to
venturacollective.com
forward slash tim dillon that's v i n c
e r o collective dot com forward slash
tim dillon
vincero is pronounced vincero
on it semiannual sale is here featuring
lowest prices of the year on our most
popular supplements food equipment and
more for two weeks only all of our
products will be on sale at huge
discounts save 25 off supplements like
alpha brain the memory in focus right
comp uses it and loves it the memory and
focus supplements is sold over a million
bottles or total human the convenient
day and night packs complete with
essential vitamins minerals herbs amino
acids which make optimization easy take
20 off all nutrition products and stock
up on some grass-fed whey protein or the
extremely delicious and nutritious
protein bites 10 off fitness equipment
like primal kettlebells and steel maces
and 50 off all digital on it programs
included on at 6 body weight and on at 6
barbell plus get up to 60 off door
busters like hydrotech instant and
shroom tech green
and exclusive free gifts too
yeah
but hurry the audit semi annual sale
ends sunday may 29th and all products
will go back to their regular prices
don't miss out on the best deals of the
year learn more at on it dot com slash
tim that is on it dot com slash gym
i love on it i use on it do you love it
yeah i use alpha brand i use all the
supplements
oh and i like the protein bites are
tasty oh they're good
the economy is really in trouble netflix
down 71
a lot of the streamers are getting
beaten up
a lot of the tech companies are getting
battered
bitcoin
falling
everybody upset
interest rates rising
real estate market starting to soften
uh the cost of debt has gone up
dramatically for all of these companies
like netflix that were running on debt
wealthy americans are buying second
passports as a plan b for their families
citing the pandemic climate change and
political turmoil well who called this
not taki but i did i said people were
gonna get the [ __ ] out of this country
i'm thinking about it myself my
grandfather was born in ireland i might
be able to get eu citizenship
uh by uh i don't know some type of
thing
um maybe i'll move in with the ant word
but the point is
people are
really starting to look at america not
as this inevitable world power anymore
they're looking at it as a place they
might want to have hey maybe we'll have
a spot there but you know because it was
during the pandemic people looking at
new york and l.a going oh maybe they're
not inevitable maybe i should just have
a spot there
now it's kind of like people are looking
at the whole entire country going hey
maybe it's not inevitable maybe i'll
just have a spot there maybe we'll just
have a home there and we can uh you know
kind of jet set around be a citizen of
the world it says here the number of
wealthy americans buying gold and
passports has skyrocketed over the past
three years the top programs grant
citizenship to foreigners who invest
millions of dollars in the country u.s
applicants are citing covid
all kinds of other things climate change
political division
and people want out
the most expensive programs range from
1.1 million in malta to 9.5 million in
austria
we see these programs as an insurance
policy a managing partner at latitude
residency and citizenship sad we've had
some billionaires approach us and ask
what's the best place to live if there's
a climate catastrophe or if there's
another storm or a global pandemic where
should i be
you know what's funny the four the
beverly hills hotel which we love sent
me a little thing they sent me a package
and they're like to all of our really
treasured guests we'd like you to write
some of your favorite memories of the
beverly hills so tell them send them
back and you know i love the beverly
hills hotel but like i don't want
homework you know but and they send you
like stationery to write it you know
you're supposed to write it on like
stationary i guess and i wanted to write
like i felt really safe there during the
riots
or something and you go like what are
you gonna what am i gonna what am i
gonna write here
and i love the beverly hills hotel but
it's like i'm not trying to do a book
report i don't want to write a what
um but it just made me think about like
all of the people that you know over the
last couple of years who've really just
started to say you know what i have a
lot of money
and i like america
and it's a great place but there's other
places too
that i may like and if there's another
pandemic or there's a climate
catastrophe which there will be or
there's a civil unrest
i would like to maybe go somewhere else
and you look a lot in the climate and
aren't there places they're going to
fare better during climate catastrophes
than other places right oh yeah yeah you
got to get out of this house
yeah what are the places that are going
to do okay
is it that coeur d'alene
idaho area is it the mountainous regions
too many fires up there
so uh you guys can think about that you
kind of got to go up where uh giannis is
up in that area up in the uh remember
the finger lakes okay around there uh
upper michigan
and uh like parts of uh like montana and
wisconsin like that's kind of it
yeah
i'll die
i'd rather die i live in upper michigan
but no but that is a i understand what
they're saying they're saying you got to
get away from the waters well you got to
get a place where and the fires and you
need fresh water to drink and to grow
crops you need a water aquifer maybe a
well no hurricanes no flooding no uh
fires no uh and no food shortages
yeah so uni and by the way
let's talk about the food shortage
because a lot of people
are saying that this is actually well
first of all this i love this this is
new and by the way you know that uh and
by the way we know i'm not a fitness
guru it's not how i've made my living
but uh i'm not claiming to be that you
know what i mean this is i'm not a
wellness expert this isn't what i do but
you know that evil billionaires do put
out
content through like a lot of times they
will
put content out through like these
wellness blogs and stuff
because like uh it'll be some version of
like three meals a day we don't think so
and you know that that's coming from
people who are trying to prepare you
for not having food
it's not about your helmet your health
and wellness that's not what it's about
tell you that right now no one really
cares about your health and wellness
they don't care if you're hot because
that's all health is it's like are you
hot do people want to [ __ ] you that's
like that's what wellness means it
really should mean like are you healthy
and whatever but that's not what it
really means it means are you [ __ ]
can you put things in your [ __ ] and
make money online it doesn't mean like
are you like what how how are your cells
like it's not all the wellness things
are about being hot there's nothing
wrong with being hot it should be the
goal right but when they when they have
these things and they do all the time
like there's just articles that are
weirdly suspicious they're like are you
drinking too much water like and you you
start going to yourself like wait a
minute who's this for and where is it
coming from and i saw one of them and i
thought about it and this is what it uh
and where is this from what uh
study fines uh study fines research in a
nutshell so
this is some think tank somebody's
bankrolling this ready
end of dinner
question mark
landmark study shows eating only during
daytime could add years to your life so
again you have the food shortages and
inflation and the cost of everything's
gone up and now the articles are
starting to come out they're like hey
you need to eat at night too
guys guys
uh you ate during the day yeah that's
when you eat
they'll start gaslighting you'd be like
uh dinner was like never it was like
never a thing to eat at night
it's like a rich people thing as a
luxury occasionally you'll have a dinner
but the vast majority of people eat
bread for breakfast and some type of
grain
and then whatever
uh old meat that we've given them
and then they're done eating by dusk
because you don't eat at night
eating primarily during the day instead
of at night could be key to longer life
researchers from the university of texas
southwestern medical center well there i
mean that's the top school in the world
uh
said it's not what you consume but when
their study finds it cutting down on
fatty and sugary foods and having meals
at the right time increase the longevity
by 35 percent experiments found the
body's
clock daily rhythms play a big part in
the benefits of a healthy diet now we
all know you shouldn't eat late at night
we all know these things we all know
that you should eat in a certain window
nobody's arguing about that what's funny
to me is that the articles just comes
out
coincidentally as everybody's talking
about like a food shortage these
articles start to trickle out where
they're like uh i don't know about
dinner that's a little archaic should
eat during the day don't you want to be
healthy
uh within that in mind study authors say
people should restrict their dining to
the most active hours during the day
which for most americans are nothing
there is zero
least at night you have a night terror
you're somewhat active most americans
are sloth-like for the entire day
they're koala bears and at least at
night they're slightly active because
they wake up uh in terror because they
owe so much money to everybody and they
run around their house and they're
having like acid reflux and they're
spitting up
uh hot you know garbage that they just
ate at a fast food place and so at least
they're a little active at night during
the day
in lab animals tracked over four years a
reduced calorie diet alone extended
survival by 10 however the improvement
increased significantly with an
exclusive nighttime feeding schedule
i'm sorry uh
uh the combination tacked on an extra
nine months to their typical two-year
average lifespan however the improvement
um
uh however the improvement increased
significantly with an exclusive
nighttime feeding schedule i don't know
what that means what does that mean
they seem to be reversing themselves
lead author professor joseph takashi
says a similar plan for people would
restrict eating to daytime hours okay
because animals are active at night
eating less is known to boost health
studies on a ver you know
so
again this is what's coming here it's
it's not
listen again we all know that you
shouldn't be eating [ __ ]
cheeseburgers at [ __ ] 9 p.m
what this is really say here they go
does intermittent fasting really work
this is the next
thing to
watch this the next thing's going to be
just fasting
they're like how about fasting forget
[ __ ] the intermittent just fast
we don't have any more food for you
we've spent all the money
sorry
so it's just funny now bring up
something about these food shortages
because
people are panicking a friend of mine
texted me she's like do you think the
food shortages are real and i'm like
yeah i believe they probably are oh
these are bad headlines baby formula
shortages baby formula
a big shortage right now
of baby formula
go up to the first one baby uh the baby
food one parent stressed over baby
formula shortage and limits quote it's
insane
a baby
formula shortage has turned into a
nationwide food crisis for parents
across our country desperate to feed
their
infants retail outlets have seen a 30
drop in the availability of some popular
brand well then just start writing
articles about that is your infant too
reliant on formula
is your infant a fat [ __ ]
our new blog about infant wellness as
your infant should start how about they
start doing intermittent fasting
retail outlets have seen 30 percent drop
in the availability of some
popular brands due to supply chain
issues labor shortages inflation safety
concerns
were you breastfed or bottle fed
breast i was bottle fed it's interesting
um
bottle fed
go into that because i'm curious now
as to
because everyone said like the bottle
fed kids were going to be all [ __ ] up
maybe they are i haven't looked at the
stats but the breast fed kids are [ __ ]
up you want me to see bottle fed versus
breastfed yeah are there any stats on
that because isn't this couldn't this be
if you're making your own milk do you
need the formula i'm i'm ignorant of
this maybe either
infants who are formula fed or fed a
mixture of formula and human milk were
2.8 times more likely to develop
gastrointestinal infection
than those who were exclusively
breastfed so it's a little better to
breastfeed
looks like it now why don't
now not all women breastfeed and it's a
thing right is it health
uh yeah well you don't also don't want
to take the breast out everywhere you go
so it's just easier to just have it in
the bottle and and everything and it
hurts the woman too the the baby will
chew on the on the nipple
yeah
well my whole thing is is there a cure
for this if everybody just starts
breastfeeding
would that solve this
i i guess so right because i don't know
it's unlimited it comes from the breast
right let me google do you need do you
have to feed babies formula do you have
to
feed
when your toddler is 12 months old you
can switch from infant formula
to plain whole cow's milk
so it's a year
okay or fortified unsweetened soy
beverage if you want him to be a soy boy
um so the deal is it's only this is a
year but it's still a problem
if you can't get formula in a year and
for whatever reason if you can't
breastfeed
and
the children are uh you know suffering
didn't biden just came out goes it'll
get worse
that's always nice
it's always good when when when the
politicians
make it
feel better
well this was what he said on march 25th
because it's gonna be real
that's great
it's gonna be real man
that's always good to hear but he just
said something recently it's on drudge i
think he said like it's gonna get worse
i think he's like hey man
i know it's bad now
but it's actually going to be uh worse
you know you're not gonna
you think things are rough
it's gonna actually get worse
biden finally admits soaring inflation
is a real tough problem suggests it may
get worse here play this
uh
clip
okay he's like you're gonna have less
formula
you have you think he hit you think you
have no formula now
he goes formula
buying a bottle of baby formula is going
to be like buying a bottle of cristal
did you take any reservoir
[Music]
in this country do you take any
responsibility or policies i think our
policies help not hurt
think about what they say
the vast majority of the
of the uh
of the economist
think that this is going to be a real
tough problem to solve but it's not
because of
spending
we've brought down the deficit the
bottom line is how much
does america owe
how much in the whole are we going
we're reducing that
well that makes you feel better
if
if you're sitting there and the formulas
run dry and you're sitting there with a
screaming infant and then he comes out
and he's like where were you met people
or no
it's not about spending
it's about how much do we owe
we're reducing that
we're fixing that
come on
free email services like gmail and yahoo
aren't really free you pay with your
privacy in fact the internet giants like
big tech bank on exploiting your data by
selling it to the highest bidder your
business plan google has it your medical
records yahoo consultant drug companies
we got to be concerned about email
surveillance and the risks that come
with it from free service providers
that's why i use start mail
it makes me feel safe again start mail
keeps my email private period every
email can be encrypted even if the
recipient doesn't use encryption when
you delete an email and start mail it's
gone forever and start milli using their
own servers not amazon's which means
that they can be put out of business
like uh they can't be put out of
business like parlor was switching to
start mail is seamless too you can
easily transfer all your current email
data and there's no starting from
scratch you get unlimited anonymous
aliases the future protects your main
email address from spam and phishing
attacks so when you're giving your email
to a company but want to protect your
identity start mail could generate a
shareable alias email so people can't
sell your information
and
and they can be deleted anytime i love
start mail and you do because you know
what it does it makes me feel safe when
i communicate exactly
start securing your email privacy with
start mail sign up today and you'll get
50 off your first year go to
startmill.com
timd that's start mail with the t
start
s-t-a-r-t
mail.com timd for 50 off your first year
startmail.comtimd i'm telling you right
now when we find out what big tech is
really doing to all of us and how much
data they're harvesting data is like
surpassed oil is the most profitable
commodity we're going to be livid it's
your job it's on you right now to
protect yourself whether you're
communicating with email or whatever
you're doing whether it's vpns or
whatever you're doing what you really
need to start doing
is really taking extra care to protect
yourself online because these companies
are harvesting your information
all the time so start mail is a great
way to support private email
correspondences
everyone should ditch spy mail and
switch to start mail
i mean it's really ugly how much is
bitcoin down huh it's like at 31 000
right now it may be time to buy soon buy
some coin ooh it's even down lower it's
30. it could be
i don't know is it the death knell
i don't think so
is it at the floor it could be smarter
people than me think it's still there's
still some
blood in the water
and
i just you know
i'm uh i don't know i'm not ready to buy
any yet
i'm not ready to buy any yet but
it could be
i like this
vox why the stock market and bitcoin
keep crashing
the stock market's panicking but you
don't have to
yeah i mean it it's really uh if you
have money now it'll be a great time to
make money you can buy stocks
at you know it you know when they hit a
floor or when you think they're at a
floor you can buy bitcoin this is when
people get rich right rich people get
even richer
when they have the opportunity to go in
and swoop in and buy things
um
that other so i mean i don't know if you
are in a financial position to monitor
this stuff and go in and buy some stuff
it could be nice
and you could look back on it years from
now why don't you but why don't we buy
baby formula and sell it
like like buy it up in bulk
could we do that is there any law
preventing us probably but from buying
baby formula in bulk and then going to
poor areas and selling it
yeah because grocery stores can buy them
in bulk right so so could we i mean it's
a great idea to just buy instead of
merch
on our website let's just sell baby
formula at an increased cost it's called
arbitrage
it happens all the time
buy baby formula and sell it to be and
let's be uh it's not the time this is
great now they're overturning roe v wade
nobody has formula
those babies do not need to be here
truly and the reality is those babies
are gonna show up hungry
for formula which we don't have so it's
time for the supreme court to [ __ ]
relax
and [ __ ] extend abortion to seven or
eight months even
really on the operating today at this
point the economy demands on the
operating table
depending on the price of formula that
day you should be able to
get rid of it
if formula is high
the week before you're about to give
birth
they should have a special
before they overturn roe v wade what if
they did this they're gonna overturn it
but they said for the next six months
because of the shortages on formula and
how expensive everything is we are
planning to overturn roe v wade but for
the next six months abortion is legal up
into and including day of birth
just to
you know
just get in while the gettin's good
and then we're banning it
but up to including the day of birth
where they will you literally give birth
to a baby
and they give it lethal injection
[Laughter]
on the opera
what on the operating table
because right now we financially can't
do it it's like have you ever wanted a
puppy and your parents had to go we
can't do it right now
people are desperate
we we can't even control the babies we
have here in our country we certainly
can't be bringing we should do a
chinese-style ban on birth
uh-huh not i'm not even kid for 100
get a bitcoin if you want to have a kid
and see if you can watch that for a year
with the highs and lows of that it's
[ __ ] pretty much like a lot of people
say oh having kids greatest thing in
your life have you owned a bitcoin
the highs and the lows oh your kids your
kids just won a a [ __ ] hockey game
everyone's happy who bitcoin's high oh
the kid broke his arm in the next hockey
game i'm worried bitcoin's low
a bitcoin is a perfect uh
replacement for a child all the highs
and lows that you used to get from a
traditional nuclear family structure you
can now get from cryptocurrency yes or
yes yes
you don't need a bunch of children
running around your house
unless you're the ant word you want to
do blood rituals with them you don't
need them running around your house
you can get all of that fulfillment and
drama from bitcoin
if you own crypto and you watch it go up
and down
what do people do when they have a kid
they have all this mommy [ __ ] right
mommy bloggers they watch youtubes of
mommy we've got that the crypto
community has all of that you can watch
a will clementi that uh [ __ ] uh 19
year old autistic twink and he just sits
here and he rattles off things all day
listen all you can clearly
[Music]
replace your need to have children
with
the bitcoin
world just buy a bitcoin a bitcoin costs
30 000
okay
that's essentially
the startup cost of having a baby when
you think of the cribs and the stuff and
it only gets more expensive from there
my point is that it's incredibly
irresponsible right now
to have children we need to put like a
year or two
moratorium on all birth in america
where if you if
you're laughing but i'm not wrong the
reason china's overtaking us is because
they don't get emotional about this [ __ ]
moratorium on old birth
for one to two years
of every race don't even come at me with
that it's not about that every race
close the doctors and hospitals down in
the ob gyns close it down treat mothers
like criminals put them in jail
and forcibly abort their children for a
period of one to two years until the
economy can rebound and give them crypto
while you're give them crypto
so they can [ __ ] have something to
watch and care about every day and look
after give them cryptocurrency take
their babies from them
and kill them
we don't have the money it's incredibly
selfish to keep bringing life into this
world when we have artificial
intelligence ai we have enough simulated
life we don't need any more biological
life we've got enough
elon things are getting better elon musk
is buying twitter he's going to let me
threaten to kill my aunt on twitter
again
things are gonna be okay
elon's gonna let me uh
put my answer dress on twitter and tell
people to go kill her
i think isn't that what this is about
isn't elon buying twitter
specifically so that i can encourage my
fans to go kill my aunt
if that's not what it's about i'm not
even excited about it anymore that's my
question
my question is simply
i'm sick of this baby [ __ ] all the time
i'm sick of arguing about it
i'm saying i'm let's let's not only
should we not ban roe v wade
we should ban birth
go the other way and just until
inflation comes down
until the cost surprise how bad is the
the the cost right now of the food
the cost of actual foods of actual food
yeah find out how much it costs let's
see if there's a list of like top 10
foods and how much they cost i just
spilled this water so i'm so passionate
you want me to go get a towel
no okay
can you look up the foods cause i'm
curious about here we go here's an item
by item look at how much more expensive
your groceries are due to inflation
let's go
read some of them off
okay
a bag of orange first of all
first of all
first of all
we
it is so funny
how disgusting our country is
by the sixth choice
it just is disgusting
tell everybody
so bag of orange is up 14
okay ground beef two pounds of beef up
13
lando lakes margarine
up 11
i'm rounding it's 11.4 eglin's best eggs
up 11
milk up 11 now here's where we get
disgusting
now by the way this was just a general
article about the groceries of americans
ready just tells you something
enterman's classic rich frosted donuts
16 outs
these are your needs this is your
necessities
these this was pitched go up go to the
title again the title is
title of this here's an item by item
look at how much more expensive your
groceries are due to inflation
so they're talking about just general
like groceries
okay
enterman's donuts under that hungry man
boneless fried chicken dinner
what gas station attendant
is this for hungry man boneless fried
chicken is up 11
starbucks coffee is up 10 campbell's
soup
up 10
chips ahoy cookies is up 8.5
two heads of lettuce
which no one is buying is up eight
percent
apples are up seven point eight corn
flakes is up seven spam
classic canned ham is up seven percent
spam
spearmint chewing gums up seven percent
wonder bread's up six and a half soda
two packages of 12. well you need 24.
you need 24 uh cans of soda
that's a five percent
of course you need 24 cans of soda maybe
you're a family of three
haagen-dazs vanilla ice cream
well this i don't like hugging us
vanilla ice cream is up three point
three percent rust and potatoes are up
three percent so
a trip to the grocery store for a family
right now is crazy
it's really bad and there's no end in
sight
these [ __ ] billionaires they've got
the inside line on everything even
inflation can't touch them but i'm about
to walk it you know people go to me all
the time they say to me they go you look
like you figured it out what do you what
do i invest in stocks no real estate no
crypto maybe but not on your life here's
what you do invest in fine art well tim
i don't have 100 million dollars how am
i going to invest in fine art oh well
what if there was a company that allowed
you to buy a share of a piece of fine
art that literally goes up in value and
beats the s p 500 and what if it was
called masterworks dot io cd that's
right no that's the way their
regulations are what it was what if it
was called masterworks that's right
picasso basquiat banksy
lots of these mofos are investing in man
amounts of contemporary art why because
36 percent average historical price
appreciation when inflation is at 3
percent or outpacing the average total
return of the [ __ ] s p for the last
25 years now there's someone who could
beat them with their own game who's
making art available to people like us
i'm talking about masterworks i've
mentioned it before and i think this
idea is genius and a lot of you seem to
agree so i use my massive swinging
influence to get all of our listeners
priority access to skip their wait list
just go to masterworks dot art slash jam
do it right now go to masterworks dot
art slash channel that's masterworks dot
art slash gym and see important
regulation disclosures at masterworks
dot io slash tv that's masterworks dot
io slash cd for important regulations
and disclosures but masterworks dot art
slash tim is where you start your
investment journey it's gonna be amazing
get into it and see important regulation
a disclosures at masterworks dot io cd
many people are bald and it's
unfortunate but you don't have to be the
best way to stop being bald is to keep
the hair you already have on your head
keeps offers uh an amazing way to do it
they have convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
24 7 care and support it's low cost okay
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time they
are like 35 or something i'm telling you
right now
you gotta do it they have everything
your hair needs delivered straight to
your door with discreet packaging and
proven results really what keeps does is
they take like the generic versions of
the two fda approved and great uh
ingredients that prevent hair loss the
two biggest uh you know hair loss
treatments and they give you the generic
versions and you save a lot of money how
about that that's great it is if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to k-e-e-p-s dot com tim dillon
if you're trying to keep your hair and
you enjoy our show man what a cool thing
to do go to k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim
dillon that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
tim dylan to receive your first month of
treatment for free what
to receive your first month of treatment
for free go to k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
timberland and keep the hair that you've
got on your head keep the hair that you
got on your head now keep that head that
you got on your head do you have a
problem with your hair get your hair
homie g get your hair keep your hair on
your head now we do like the adword get
back here
keep your hair on your head leave your
hair on your head keep your hair on your
head
go to keeps folks don't [ __ ] around with
me
can i just say one thing no we know so
many people that use this and it really
does work we know many people do i know
many people they're keeping their hair
with keeps yeah it really does work it
works
well there are there are recipes and and
this is where i get a little i kind of
have some life hacks
because i do know there are some recipes
that
you can make for a family now you come
from a large family right right
there are recipes that you can make for
your family that will hold up
right there are like things that you can
make that will last several days
you know every day doesn't have to be a
new meal
really
you can make
like recipes that are
you know resilient and they stand the
test of
time for people
um and there are a lot there's a lot of
them
that fam like let's say you had a family
let's say you you're an american family
you've got a you have a man
and you have a woman
and you have two children
okay
and you need to feed that unit
for five days
monday through friday
no monday through friday okay
okay
monday through friday
what you could do
how much is a 50 pound bag of rice
if you got a 50
pound
bag of rice
okay
take a look at that rice
it's 30.
that is a fifty pounder right there
thirty dollars yeah take a look at that
rice land white long grain rice
fifty dollars
i'm gonna show you people a little trick
how much ragu tomato sauce
what
ragu
how much is it is my question because
it's what 30 for the rice
yeah 30. 30 for the rice i want a big
jar you go to the biggie okay that big
in how much is that 8.5 pounds that's
right i like sauce and pounds
right because my aunt used to make this
for her children my aunt made this meal
for her children
i'm not kidding not not the one i just
like the one i like but she made this
for her children i'm gonna tell you
about a meal that you can make for your
family that will eat through the week
eat through the week from monday tuesday
wednesday thursday friday
how much is that ragu 11 39. let's do
some math let me get a calculator yeah
i'd like you to because we're we're
putting together a meal that eats
through the week it's what you need to
do to survive these times
and i am a little bit of a gourmand i
can tell you exactly
what to do
to make it special okay
so right now 41
we have what we've got eight pounds of
tomato sauce ragu
and we have 50 pounds of white rice
[Music]
okay
ingredient number three american cheese
how much can you get american cheese for
i'm talking about a block okay a block
go to deets and watson right there this
one right here
yeah deets and water no not white
american yellow i like the color okay so
that's gonna be same price same price
what do we got how much uh we got uh
half a pound for four bucks
so
two pounds is how much
uh that would be 32 ounces uh
uh
16 right i'm sorry my math is i'm like
[ __ ] but 16 for cheese add that to
the 41. okay
and i may do that i may make this
on the show
to show you how to do it
here's what you're going gonna do you're
gonna get a big pot
and you're gonna boil the white rice
okay okay
when the rice is not all of it not all
of it okay
you don't splooge all over the woman
before she's pleasured
you take a little bit of the rice that
you need however what whatever will fill
your family you know
how many cups of rice per person two
cups three cups uh about two cups about
two cups of rice per per person more
than a serving there yeah more than a
shirt but you give them a lot it's
because this is what they're eating this
is there there's nothing else so you
give them a good amount and you take
you take the ragu tomato sauce you mix
it up with the rice
okay
and you could do the ragu with the
vegetables in it because then it is some
vegetables and you mix it with the rice
you melt you go to the microwave
after you've done that you melt
two slices of american cheese or you
could shred it
on top
of
the white rice and the ragu tomato sauce
and you mix it up you mix up the cheese
and the sauce and the rice and then you
feed
your family
well why are you saying no
why are you saying no
you privileged prick
what's what are you saying no for
it's like dog food no it's not it's not
like dog food at all it's people need to
live
you sick [ __ ]
people need to live
it's not dog food it's white rice with
ragu tomato sauce and then melted
american cheese through it
and it gives you enough
you can survive for a week
with how much money how much did that
all cost uh that was let's see here
so that was 57.38
divided by five okay divided by five
uh
11.47 for 11.47
you can feed your entire family for the
week
is that a problem
now i'm gonna do school lunch
okay i just gave you dinner okay
breakfast breakfast is easy right
breakfast you could just buy big tubs of
oatmeal oh yeah yeah right easy easy
i'm not even dignifying breakfast with
an ant you can get free breakfast half
the time okay you go pretend you work at
a company and get their breakfast you
can get free breakfast
if you want to get it it's easy to get
free breakfast go attend a seminar
they'll give you a free breakfast
now
and you don't need breakfast either
for school lunch
this is a very easy thing to do if you
want to make school lunch for your kids
okay
you get a bag of white rice
you get
ragu tomato sauce
and you get american cheese
you cook the rice
and you mix it in with the tomato sauce
and then you melt the cheese through the
rice
you get a tupperware
and you put it in it
and you send them to school with it
that is easy
so if people are complaining about
inflation
and that they don't have any money or
you could give your kids to the edward
either way i don't care i'm just saying
it's an easy meal
it's an easy me it's not a big deal
well i'm sorry what did you eat duck
alarange every night
is that what you ate with your family
what was a meal that you people would
have i don't know like you know the
don't you eat sandwiches on like
holidays yeah turkey sandwiches yeah so
i mean what are you doing
what are you chicken spaghetti yeah
which is like olives and uh is that
worse than what i said
not really no no
i'm sorry is that better than what i
said like
chicken spaghetti is that a thing the
thing you described is that a real thang
or did you just make it my aunt used to
make it for her children what's it
called and one of them's a mover he's
doing fine
listen what do you mean what's it called
it's called rice
with tomato sauce and american cheese
and you would eat it she tried to make
it for me once i threw the plate in her
head i said don't come near me
but that's what it is that's a way to
eat you you want a meal that'll eat
through the week eat through the week
what about stuffing
can't you make a big pot of stuffing for
your family
and just give them stuffing
stovetop that's pricey
yeah it's up there
it's that is very expensive
stovetop stuffing
yeah here's an off-brand from you know
what my father used to make mashed
potatoes that started out as powder
oh yeah yeah that's like a divorce dad
meal you get some powdered mashed
potatoes he would take steak london
broil he'd burn it he'd put it on a
bagel
that's like a divot yeah that's right
idahoan
this is instant potatoes
this is what people in this country eat
they eat tyson
holly farms
chicken they eat instant mashed potatoes
i mean this is what people eat
and there's nothing wrong with it
this is our diet
this is our culture
yeah look at this by the way pull that
up this actually looks great
tomato rice with cheddar and you're
acting like it's a like a problem it
looks like olive garden
i'll have got he'd be lucky as hell to
be at olive garden that's what i'm
saying yeah it looks it actually doesn't
look bad you'd be lucky as hell to be in
an olive garden with the way things are
going in this country
that's the meal you make rice sauce
cheese move on
or you know those oyster rat crackers
you get for free with the soup
yes
if you
give your kids like so for example
you can get those oyster rat crate you
might be able to go to a restaurant if
you go to red lobster at the end of the
night you look sad
and go do you have any leftover oyster
crackers they might give you some money
also here's the other thing folks if
things are beg
you know like
beg at local restaurants
and if you have cute kids send the kids
in
to like applebee's and to shift and and
tell them go listen if you turn the
waterworks on a little bit we might be
able to get something
send your chil
this is america
it's about ingenuity
it's not about
sitting on your couch and feeling sorry
for yourself it's about sending your
children in to local
themed restaurants to beg for food
that's
america that's why we fought all these
wars
if you don't have anything to eat send
your children olive garden
crying
at 9 55
and ask and just say we don't have any
food
my parents are too embarrassed to ask
can you give us food
send your children
into the olive garden five minutes
before clothes
and ask for leftover food say i don't
even care even if it was on someone
else's plate i don't even know obviously
they're not going to give you food off
of someone else's plate but enhancing
the desperation will help you
i mean
or you could just sit back and take it
but if i know something about america
the greatest country on earth land of
the free home of the brave
it's that we don't
we
really
when the going gets tough
the tough
send their children to in to beg for
food
so
and then you can all go home
with the food that you just got from the
cheesecake factory they give you some
leftover food maybe they give you a big
thing of mashed taters
and then you could go home and you could
watch selling sunset or one of the real
estate shows
and you could tell your children how
great it is that we live in a country
where people paid 10 million dollars to
live in [ __ ] boxes
stacked on top of each other on top of
the
sunset heroin strip
and you can explain that to them while
they eat their
mashed potatoes that they were given
because they cried at the cheesecake
factory
during clothes
or you could give them to the antwood
whatever but
that's the way i feel
timberlandcomedy.com there are no live
dates nothing to buy tickets to leave me
alone uh we don't have any merch either
go away special will be out in june
it'll be irrelevant but it'll be fun
it's funny it's good it's fine
patreon.com the tim dillon show for
exclusive
content we are going to catch up on some
of the episodes we've been doing all the
regular patreon episodes but we have a
higher tier called the rothschilds tear
the rothschilds tier
um and we are going to do all their
episodes this week we owe them a lot and
we're going to do a big episode this
week
um
[Music]
so it's a lot of fun
over there on patreon a lot of bonus
content
we will be
[Music]
around uh all the time now in this
studio you're gonna see us so much
you're gonna get sick of that
but i will tell you i i will tell you
this right now and i and i mean this i i
do believe in america and i believe that
we're gonna be able to get through this
time
which is difficult
economically
by begging
[Music]
uh chain restaurants for food having
children go in there and beg them
for food and
you tell your children go listen
and you can listen
do you want to eat the rice thing again
they're going to go i'm sick of that
you're going to go all right well we're
going to
drive them to it drive them to a sonic
and have them cry
and maybe to give the family a milkshake
it's the greatest country in the world
i mean it is
isn't that what all these people keep
saying on uh you know
it's the greatest country in the world
because you can do this
this is what makes it great because you
can your children
can can cry
and go into
uh steak and shake or
whatever
and
krispy kreme
and they can cry and go my family
doesn't have any money
they don't they don't have any money
and
they won't they're they won't ask can i
have a donut
and they might give you 12 donuts they
might give you a whole dozen
we're gonna get through it together and
the the way to get through it
is to be smart to be smart about
everything you know
i mean
i think we're gonna handle it a food
shortage by the way is
hard to understand because
um it seems plentiful food seems so
plentiful out there
but there are a lot of families that are
struggling with
the ability to feed themselves
and if there is a
charity
that you know of
that you can like recommend to me
that will help
like families that are in need of
food
let me know what that charity is you
know because it is
it is a
tough predicament it's that certain
people are in
um
but
i before i donate i want to speak to the
people and tell them to try this first
i'll give you food if you try this and
it doesn't work
but try this
you got a couple of cute kids who might
give them food not taki
don't send taki in there
they'll call the cops
that won't work with taki
don't send taki into a chili's
i'm saying
for the other people it's the greatest
country in the world and i think that we
should all just
understand uh that so
next week very exciting we have our uh
summer special episode which will be uh
all of the uh places you can go on
vacation on a budget we're very excited
about that because there are so many
places uh
that you can go now
and eat uh and i'm sorry end of vacation
on a real budget
like a real budget
um for like hundreds of dollars you
could take your family on a trip because
i think everybody needs a trip it's the
summer we've been through a hell of a
two years and a lot of people are going
to do a staycation they're going to get
the family together and everybody watch
the gringo poppy but you also
want to go out there and be able to take
them to the amusement park
and you know give them food
so we'll have that for you when we come
back thank you good night